- Look at us.
- I just love that you've been married,
in my world, for years.
- Well, I was married once before,
a while ago.
- I was like, no, no,
I thought to him.
- Oh to him?
- Because you sent me videos
of y'all on vacation like--
- I know--
- I love them.
They're the best--
- I know,
- Married couple.
- By the way,
I love drunk texting Kelly.
(Kelly laughing)
When we're out, I'm like
"Hey, Kelly. It's us."
- It's my favorite.
- You're probably like,
"What is she doing?"
- No, I have a few
friends in the limelight
that randomly do that.
[Hoda] I love doing it.
- Pentatonix are one as well.
[Hoda] Pentatonix?
- And it's great.
Yeah I'm like y'all should not do this.
This is black mail.
I have black mail.
(laughing)
- I never do that.
I'm afraid people will show it.
Never send that to Blake Shelton.
- Oh.
(laughing)
- Never.
I know you love Blake, but he will take-
- I don't trust.
- Never trust him with something
important footage wise.
[Hoda] What did he do?
- No, I, I, just don't trust him.